[Music]
nothing of note other than finding and
promptly declaring my intentions to my
new
contest of course oh but who will the
lucky lady be
fans of the netflix hit bridgeton are
about to find out because season two is
officially a go
and joining me now is the vi count
bridgeton himself
jonathan bailey i am so excited to talk
to you but how long have you known about
season two we're just finding out
did you know it was gonna happen well i
think you can tell from the length of my
beard when i've started to grow up those
modern jobs so that was about three
days expect season two shooting this
spring
to revolve around jonathan's anthony
bridgerton and his
quest for love and of course we're
hoping for more steamy scenes
you guys have an intimacy coach right
what does that person actually do before
and after the scenes it's amazing and i
cannot believe that
the industry you know there was a time
where they weren't included in the
process but they basically come in you
have a one-on-one
um you talk about your personal
experiences and any boundaries you might
have before you then
deal with the actual scene
[Music]
they just make it very safe i must do
what is necessary look we did hear this
story that you once met rihanna at a
party
give me your best pitch for rihanna
playing one of anthony's love interests
i mean i'm i'm really up for it she is
um i mean the chemistry
we saw this amazing video of you and
some of your co-stars
singing can't help falling in love are
the bridgerton brothers the new jonas
brothers
you know compared to the jonas brothers
you know it's a badge of honor
hello entertainment tonight this is
jonathan bailey anthony bridgeton in
bridgeton and welcome to the set here in
the uk
we first met jonathan on the london set
back in 2019.
you were the first people who i think
visited us and set and uh thank you for
being there
since the beginning of course he's only
one of the hot stars of the gossip girl
meets 50 shades show that's streaming
now on netflix
another breakout is reggae jean paige
and whatever could your intentions be
respectful
won't believe it then there is now
all this talk of him potentially playing
the next james bond
give me your thoughts can he do it he
can do it yeah i mean
he could save a nation for sure